[Music]
instagram has made celebrities out of
all sorts of people not me not you
what do you consider that was youtube so
not necessarily don't give the credit to
instagram yeah maybe not the word
celebrity but famous
instagram famous i want like at least a
million
um you gotta show your butt you're so
greedy
mine stopped growing mine's going down
i don't think i post enough i post like
every two weeks can you guys follow us
again can you like unfollow and just
follow us again
share us with your friends yeah we
didn't
we missed out on the tick tock thing we
didn't do the tick tock have you seen
tick tock oh
it's like so many edits how do you guys
edit so much like
like the phone like editing on the phone
it's hella easy they do the work for you
really still yeah they cut the parts
that's kind of you just add it together
and it's like oh [ __ ] that was a
seamless
transition that was awesome they like
figure it out then they sync it to the
music
well at least i'm talking about the
gopro editor that shit's [ __ ] sick
and you just drag it in and you're just
like oh [ __ ] that was tight they did it
for me that makes me feel so old
because i'm like man it makes way more
sense to just import the footage into
your laptop
and then get final cut and actually
like that's that's that's the real way
shortcut like you just drop
the gopro footage into your phone
and then in the app it already edits it
for you oh
i've seen that yeah premiere on the
phone is surprisingly good
adobe premiere really but you can't use
copyright music
oh well no then you send it into tick
tock and you have a whole library there
i know but i'm trying to sync certain
like movements we're just trying to boom
okay leave us alone
let us be boomers yeah i want to boom
that's the most boomer song you could
have thrown into the mix
good job i like it i'm brand but yeah so
what is the
the craziest like thing you've ever seen
become insta-famous
a [ __ ] cholo on a skateboard okay
what do you mean that's a thing well
that's not insta-famous he was tick-tock
famous
he's famous on both yeah he's on
everything he's a fan so like besides
people there are
things that get famous angelina jolie's
leg on twitter she had her own twitter
twitter account yeah her leg only [ __ ]
so in like internet world that's like
how many years ago
i know it was long it was like a hundred
years like an egg or some [ __ ]
oh yeah the brown egg yeah something
like that right there was like an almost
liked egg on the world or something
that's pretty nice
that's pretty crazy famous from counting
one two three four
five julia has an eggplant account oh
yeah
is it still alive well she got it cast
it or something she gotta cast it so now
it's forever alive
yeah oh i follow an instagram account
where this dude all he
or he posts some other stuff but his
main thing and the reason why he's
popular is because
he posts photos of homes that have
shutters that make no sense so it'd be
like a huge ass
round window and like tiny little square
shutters
next to it like it's the most ridiculous
[ __ ] ever but it's really funny
i like that account i i i see you
following it all the time i'm always
laughing i'm like
this is ridiculous who does this to
their house all right so
to add to the list of crazy things to go
uh to be insta-famous
specifically instant famous is
a puddle oh come on a puddle in
russia wow in the far east city of
yusuno sakalinsky you tried
it might be a cool puddle and what if
the sun comes out the puddle's gone
no because it's being called the
invincible puddle
and it's been constantly filled with
water
for 25 years no way
and it's never evaporates well one it
never evaporates because this place
out of all the photos that's ever been
posted about this place it always looks
like it's raining
first of all secondly over the past 25
years
the locals have actually been trying to
get it fixed it's
so it started off as a pothole and then
it grew
and it just became a road it's on the
road yeah and it just became this huge
like gigantic hole
filled with water and it just never
evaporates because it's constantly
raining there
it's always cold so it's never hot
enough to even have sun beating down on
it to evaporate anything
and it just keeps getting bigger and
bigger and bigger i wonder if socklin
people live there
what is that i think it's like a tribe
why did you know the east part of russia
is all asians
oh yeah it's not white people true
like kazakhstan like they look kind of
asian
i just yeah i thought they were all like
white
i don't know when you hear russia right
you think that's sure i think white
people
yeah they have a lot of ethnic uh
minorities within russia
russia i think asians with blue eyes oh
that's what i think i think they're
actually really asian
they just don't look it but on the
inside i think they're oh like that
yeah yeah wait wait explain i don't get
it what do you mean like
in the inside what do you mean like when
i talk to um
some of my russian friends they got
their asses beat [ __ ] hard too
i was a cultural culturally like
extremely asian
and like and continentally yeah
continentally
and then also just like the respect for
elders
like you can't tell your dad to shut the
[ __ ] up like that kind of that just
sounds like
what are you talking about sounds like
every other culture i've heard of some
cultures where it's okay dude it's not
like every other culture except for
american culture yeah
all right i knew i had to ask i knew i
needed a probe because something was up
no i thought i thought all of russia was
like
you know dudes that look like putin and
[ __ ] they just get bigger and bigger and
bigger
like the more north you go yeah or just
yeah even all the way to the east and
then i was looking at pictures and
there's actually like some
um chinese looking people that were
speaking russian and i'm like oh cool
they're like bilingual
and it's like wait no they're not
chinese or they're not mongolian
they're just russians oh yeah i mean
that entire kazakhstan area everyone
looks asian yeah
i i know exactly what like look you're
talking about
i mean the dean was saying like the part
that of afghanistan that touches
like russia and like part of china a
little bit like he has
a lot of people in his family that just
look east asian too
damn that's a trip man yeah we were in
turkey uh
for a layover like i remember seeing
just a whole bunch of like
like uh covered up asians and i was like
whoa
like they're wearing hijabs and stuff
but like they look straight up like
asian asian and in turkey and turkey
yeah speaking
like the local language and all that
stuff and i was like because when you
think turkey
well at least when i think turkey i
think middle eastern or white
you see the two kind of cultures there i
didn't think like
yeah more like asian i was tripping out
when we had a layover in panama
one time and there was just like a whole
bunch of chinese people speaking spanish
i was like what panama has a high like i
don't know why
is it because of the canal probably
that's probably what it is
yeah well did they have chinese
restaurants we were in the airport yeah
we
only stayed in the airport what were
they doing were they working
no they were traveling yeah like they
look like locals traveling
yeah look locally yeah but then like
there was this one family for example
where the dad was like he looks just
like
straight up chinese and his kids looked
mixed and the wife looked like
a latina like a panda minion i don't
know how to panic
i don't know but yeah and then just
seeing like that blended family i'm like
that's so cute and they were like the
dad was just speaking perfect spanish
and i was just like what that's crazy
they're probably talking [ __ ] about you
too
but look at that they're [ __ ]
speaking english it's all weird
true but yeah so back to this puddle we
got
the famous invincible puddle of russia
and uh it pretty much every single photo
looks like this that looks like
followers that looks like taika
sixteen thousand followers
within russia and anyone that has heard
of it like it's gotten so popular people
are going
to this puddle and taking pictures
there's a tourist puddle now it's a
tourist puddle yeah
it's it's a celebrity what's the
significance is it like
that's a tight puddle i never seen a
dope puddle like that before because
it's lasted so long it's impressive
and the fact that it's gotten bigger 25
years 25 years puddle
like this water is probably 25 years old
i can kind of see like my
step dad being impressed by that and
he's like oh we got to go to russia man
we gotta take a picture and then like
he's like chilling with all of his
friends he goes did you know
that i saw a puddle that last 25
years and i can see all these geezers
getting in a circle and talking about
that that sounds like a grandpa ass
story yeah and i'm like damn that's
tight yeah wait wait is that the puddle
still
yes that this is the puddle once it
rains a little bit more
yeah what point does it stop becoming a
puddle and it turns into what's next
you just call it flood what a pond yeah
a pond
yes and then the most the most viral
photo that they did take
was when these girls showed up with
surfboards and they took a photo
and they're standing on the ground next
to it so apparently
what is that like ankle deep i think so
it seems like it
seems like step on it like the board
can't even move because it's like so
thin
that's funny that is a thing that i want
to do though every time i see
like things flooding in the
neighborhoods i'm like i want to be like
it's venice oh yeah like in jumanji when
they're
like they open the the house door and
then everything floods out and they're
like surfing on
the door kind of thing well they weren't
having fun she was screaming but yeah
it's all perspective though you know
what i mean like you could be
trapped in the rapids and cry or you can
just be like i'm having a blast
trapped in the rapids i'd [ __ ] be
devastated i don't know if i could yeah
i like that joe i like that perspective
but yeah so uh what the hell is that you
covered it that's it it's gone
so so for the past 25 years they've all
the locals have always been trying to
get
the authorities to fix this pothole
right to fix it
not let it grow any bigger and through
the years they've constantly done
this as a fix which is putting dirt into
it but obviously dirt
washes away and so they've done this
like a number of times and they've
yet to actually do that permanently that
costs more money and time
to do that instead of just putting
[ __ ] asphalt on it yeah i was gonna
say like can't they google how to
like create a mixture that wouldn't wash
away like
like like the locals actually take
matters in their own i mean if they're
doing this
no no then the authorities came in and
put dirty you know what's weird is
they have roads yeah they could cover
that
that's true but they don't i thought you
were
that you're gonna see that they've been
wanting to cover it for so long now it
has the popularity
then it gets covered they're like why'd
you cover it but never mind they
actually made fun of this thing that
they're like
oh um someone decided to put a blanket
over me like i think when they post
about this puddle i don't know who owns
who owns the instagram page but when
they post
they post in the voice of the puddle so
like oh someone decided to cover me in a
blankie
but little do they know the blanket will
wash away and i'll be back i'll see you
guys very soon
and they'll like they're just like
having fun with the fact that the
government does nothing about this
puddle
there are parts of russia where the
roads are completely [ __ ]
like for it's always been [ __ ] all of
its life too like i was watching a
travel show
with ewan mcgregor and it's it's like
they
cars you can't go through it unless you
have like those the the ones where the
wheels are this big
you know so they're all front end dips
in they can bounce back out again
like it's the only way to get to certain
parts of russia have you seen
their um way of getting into siberia in
these remote places
they have like it looks like some
armored truck kind of [ __ ] yeah
with like military grade like nine tires
and [ __ ]
like it's nuts wait why because it's
flooded or
well they have to off-road there's no
real road and like
sometimes they have to go through like
snow and river and ice
yeah oh we were in one of those kind of
trucks when we were in iceland we were
going over again yeah yeah yeah going
over a glacier we're on a glacier
multiple glaciers actually like two i
think but yeah so they have these
gigantic ass trucks and you have to like
strap on your [ __ ] like it's [ __ ]
crazy
it's nuts that was really funny was your
dad making any noises yeah he was having
fun
what kind of noises were you imagining i
don't know i just feel like he would
give
give good commentary
yeah true he's like this is outrageous
[Music]
man
[Music]
do
[Music]
you